sion et simuler la jambe je voudrais
demander un peu aux professeurs je suis
professeur choron cartes dans cette
émission du 1er avril vous avez vous
pensé aller jouer à un invité sérieux
qui est ma paie sort seront alors je
vous laisse vous entretenir avec lui
thierry parce que je ne sais pas de quoi
vous voulez parler justement je parlais
de des problèmes de l'hérédité et j'ai
vu une revue scientifique qui vient de
sortir aujourd'hui je crois hara kiri ou
où il y a il y a cofondé comment vous
pourrez y arriver on parle
d'insémination artificielle
c'est ça oui oui tout le monde a lu dans
la presse
c'est fou américain qui essaient de
concevoir des enfants nobel par
insémination artificielle
or chacun sait que toute société humaine
digne de ce nom a pour base inébranlable
la bêtise et la méchanceté il fallait
donc que nous réagissions nous hara kiri
journal bête et méchant nous avons donc
trouvé un malette allons débordant de
bêtises de méchanceté c'est coluche qui
nous après prodiguer son sont prêts sont
précieux liquide
ago boudard s'engage sur un terrain mais
il aurait voulu sans shaq en présence
d'un père à côté
le feu l'édiction mais peut-être son mot
à dire vers après on voulait faire dans
chaque numéro de hara kiri de ce mois ci
il y à un sachet contenant de
l'authentic sperme de coluche alors
c'est sûrement de moissac son imprésario
on a prélevé 35 ans cette charmante
demoiselle qui hélas a été inséminée
artificiellement parle moi même il y a
une semaine
elle est donc enceinte de coluche débit
jours alors je veux rassurer tout était
tout les téléspectatrices que ça
intéresse elle va très bien c'est
pourquoi je la porte est là pour en
apporter la preuve
alors si dans le foie où tout vous
pouvez m'a vite et on pourra même faire
l'accouchement télévisés et on verra le
petit monstre
vous avez encore une question à poser
aux professeurs rien moi j'aimerais bien
avoir le point de vue quand même du père
à ce point de vue là d je trouve que
dans une émission de grande écoute à une
heure aussi est vraiment pour houston
enfants elle écoute je trouve que c'est
un troupeau qui est très déplacé je suis
très choqué oui bien moi je suis très
chaud qui fit est assis à côté d'un père
alors on échoue qui tous les deux
l'épreuve de choix thiery alors on
arrive à la fin pratiquement de cette
émission on m'a dit que vous aviez
l'intention